[Music]
6. extraordinary weeks that turned
politics upside down taking down a
Chancellor and a prime minister some
mistakes were made
but looking back now with markets almost
back to normal you could be forgiven for
wondering hang on did that really all
happen
was it all just a dream
[Music]
actually this crisis was far more
complicated than the coverage at the
time might have suggested the root
causes run far deeper and most worrying
it might just have been a Tremor ahead
of an earthquake to come
but let's start with the conventional
Story the one you've probably heard
before it begins here at the treasury on
the 23rd of September quasi-quarting has
just fired the chief civil servant and
then comes the mini budget an unfunded
set of tax cuts which causes the UK to
lose its credibility and markets to go
into a tailspin
the pound fell to the lowest level
against the dollar ever yields the
implied interest rate on government debt
rocketed the overriding feeling was one
of uncertainty and there was a lot of I
think a fear and panic looking at the
screen and seeing you know bond yields
Rising five basis points 10 basis points
and it was just you know it started to
get really out of control lenders were
changing things sometimes hourly
sometimes you get noticed sometimes you
wouldn't
it was a chain reaction sweeping through
UK markets and coursing into pensions
and mortgages it was the speed and scale
of the rising interest rates
um which was problematic things that
would ordinarily happen over the space
of you know several weeks you know
demands were being made in in matter of
hours so in order to raise cash they
were forced to sell you know things like
government bonds but the problem was
they were selling government bonds when
the prices were falling
and then the price was falling further
because lots of pension schemes were
doing it at the same time
for a few terrifying days these problems
in the market that underlies the
pensions industry threatened to cause a
total meltdown the impact of that you
know these government bond yields are
The Benchmark for borrowing costs
throughout the wider economy
so the bank of England stepped into the
breach it was a very intense period it
was a lot of Midnight Oil burnt in this
building but we knew that our response
we knew our responsibilities we knew our
responsibility for financial stability
in this country and that we had to act
even as the bank acted out there in the
real world those higher Market interest
rates were feeding through into the
prices being offered by mortgage brokers
we saw rates increasing on average about
two two and a half percent overnight
which was very dramatic when you
transfer that into actual everyday pound
coins and what's that expenditure for a
client
and finally it ended up in the real
world with real painful consequences
this is Rusty in early October he saw a
property he fell in love with but in the
three days between seeing it and getting
his offer accepted his mortgage costs
went up from a thousand pounds a month
to 1400 pounds an increase of 5 000
pounds a year all because of the market
Mayhem it was a massive change and a
shock at first and I'll be honest I had
to decide do I want to change my
standard of living what do I want to
give up for this property it could be
1500 pounds tomorrow right so it was a
bit it was a bit of a risk you buy it
now or you don't you know so
um the fact that it was that external
shock was really frustrating
um and I think the biggest thing for me
was that it was the first time when
public policy really affected my life
this is the first and most important
points what just happened wasn't just
numbers on a screen it had real
consequences unfortunate consequences
says the governor but what about those
families who have already refixed their
mortgages at really high rates in the
last few weeks well I have a great deal
of sympathy for them because I think
it's just unfortunate it's very
unfortunate what has happened they were
just victims of what collateral damage
of the chaos that we've seen there was a
period of very substantial instability
which which of course you know we and
others have had to deal with do you feel
like you've been betrayed by the Prime
Minister hello thank you but that's only
the beginning of it because those higher
rates also led to well something else
something you probably remember
they claimed the scalp of the chancellor
and then his boss
financial markets effectively decided
the fate of a prime minister yes
following some mistakes in Whitehall yes
amid a backdrop of volatility but even
so it represents a watershed moment for
the UK
and not just that the former Greek
finance minister no stranger to crises
himself said the UK's drama created
contagion in other markets including
America he was advised that markets were
very nervous and then said well markets
are going to do what they do
I mean is was he was he even more
Maverick than you it was just really bad
timing by listras and quasi Carden to
issue a budget that um
essentially allowed the guild Market the
British the UK based uh government debt
Market to add to the volatility in the
United States and you know something was
going to break and I very much fear that
it was the turn of the UK to do to the
rest of the G7 to the advanced countries
what Greece had done in 2010 to the
Eurozone countries
and the markets call them out
and it's not as if they weren't warned
by the very people advising them we said
markets are in the very febrile state if
your policy actions are not clear and
not understood there will be a market
crisis so you you've won very explicitly
about this risk I said this publicly and
privately that you needed to convince
the markets that any fiscal action was
necessary not inflationary and
affordable and did they do that
no
[Music]
and that's more or less is the
conventional story that the government
was a victim of its own mistakes that
the faceless investors in the city and
Beyond were simply reacting to imprudent
Economic Policy from an impetuous new
government and there's a lot in that
but there's another more controversial
interpretation
some are asking wasn't someone else
responsible here what about the bank of
England weren't they too slow to raise
interest rates wasn't the Fatal moment
for Liz truss when Andrew Bailey
withdrew his support for the bond market
if so that would make this the key
intervention you've got three days left
now you've got to get this done when he
appeared at an event in Washington and
imposed that deadline
the message was ostensibly for pension
schemes to wind up their Affairs but
three days later the chancellor was gone
shortly followed by the Prime Minister
brighter days lie ahead thank you
[Music]
and some influential financiers are
Whispering that actually maybe it was
the bank which really sealed the prime
minister's face then again the governor
is having none of it I vehemently
disagree with this because it is based
on fallacy one that misses is and I
don't mention
as a central bank as it should be was to
address a precise Financial stability
problem so I'm afraid had we gone on
with that intervention beyond the point
that Financial stability being suitably
restored we'd have been creating another
problem which is you know what
economists tend to call a moral asset
Hazard problem I.E you know people would
say well the banking was always going to
intervene and that's wrong we did the
job we set out to do you didn't opposal
his Trust of course we didn't just
propose this trust I would never do
anything like that
yeah
the point however is that this wasn't so
simple just as it's hard to disentangle
the events of a half-forgotten dream
this story gets more complex the more
you delve into it it's easy to blame
everything on Liz truss and quasi
quateng and they clearly stoked up a
hornet's nest but even if you discount
the Wilder stories about the bank of
England
something else going on here the bank
should have been seen as politically
neutral so the very fact that you're
asking those questions the economy and
the financial markets have become used
to cheap money the worry is that as
interest rates go higher as they need to
to keep inflation in check that will
expose all sorts of Economic and
financial problems if that's right it
means the genie didn't go back in the
bottle when Liz trust resigned it means
there could well be more trouble to come
the problems haven't haven't gone away
and you know you have to wonder you know
perhaps this isn't just an isolated
incident but it could be the sort of a
trend and and you know one thing that's
particularly concerning to me is that
there's a an awful lot of debt in the
system in other words while it's
tempting to see this all as a story
about Britain and its woes what rippled
out of the city this awesome might also
have been about something else a global
system shuddering in the face of rising
interest rates you have your assets in
in foreign currency and you have your
liabilities your own currency
um stop thinking of yourselves in Monte
python-esque terms as very exceptional
and this is my criticism for my Blitz
friends either you think that you're the
best in the world or you think you're
the worst in the world well you're a
neighbor
foreign
it was very real and the coming Autumn
statement we'll make that perfectly
clear higher taxes and lower public
spending to clean up the mess except
what if our own parochial mess was only
a fragment of the bigger narrative
as the world struggles to come to terms
with the end of cheap money the real
story might only be beginning
[Music]
thank you
foreign